instant poursuite de l'épreuve de force
entre divatte que états unis alstom
grand tour en ville paralysée toute la
journée début de la médiation de
monsieur salma les premiers contacts
valéry giscard d'estaing avec le pays
cac 40 au prix spéciaux patrice duhamel
et patrick de carolis
le déficit du commerce extérieur plus un
milliard de francs en octobre un secteur
bonne santé l'agroalimentaire rasoir
impact man bonsoir nous arrivait de
téhéran ça commençait par une bonne
nouvelle semblait-il mais on envoyait
vite les limites
le choc de la diplomatie iranienne
monsieur bani sadr annoncé que tous les
otages des états unis seraient libérés
très prochainement des américains mâle
de race blanche cela concernait tout de
même semblait-il 42 personnes si un
soldat noir américain et 36 employés
pakistanais loggias et puis un peu plus
tard les étudiants qui occupent
l'ambassade des etats-unis ont annoncé
qu'il n'était pas question libérer un
seul jeune dans l'immédiat sur plein
ventre et ayant une correspondance de
thierry titi ou des gardiens de la
révolution
journée quant à lui à toulon mais
conduit dans l'américaine dominé après
la fouille de leurs bagages un
interrogatoire
quand été relâchés sans explication et
sans aucune excuse souvent que adoré de
tournure du second degré la responsable
des affaires étrangères hier avec
l'épreuve sous l'ailé a fait machine
arrière pour la présence de nitrates
bien en ligne on prend tous les deux ans
le voyage en absurdie mêmes relie bakou
autour de la foule en deuil il est
considéré avant tout selon les orateurs
invités les manifestants à donner
l'heure pour la cause de l'islam
devenu encore plus radicale et tout à
l'heure dans l'événement avait une heure
30 vous pourrez voir une fille de
l'ayatollah khomeiny à propos de cette
prise d'otages qu'il couvre de sa grande
autorité et de la guerre économique
qu'ils engagent avec les états unis
je vous laisse entendre un peu naze
extraits de son interview
blatt par le passé les américains ont
commis à l'égard du peuple iranien d
iniquité considérable aujourd'hui si
l'amérique ne comprennent pas et
continuent leur mener je veux dire que
nous devrons prendre d'autres mesures
qui ne manqueront pas nager judiciable
aux états unis
voilà c'est un avertissement pour le net
l'ayatollah ne veut pas s'arrêter dans
cette hausse et cette partie de bras de
fer avec les états unis toujours les
suites de l'arrestation du meuble dans
les territoires occupés par israël la
cisjordanie et gaza c'est la paralysie
administrative avec des missions de 25
mères grève générale projet de grève de
la faim de guignen car quand on
israélien il faut mettre en place les
fonctionnaires pour coiffer toutes les
municipalités de cisjordanie une
correspondance de notre envoyé spécial
12h04 est complètement dans les faits
depuis lundi dernier
javani est maintenant demandé actions
esi jordanienne écoles commerces et les
palestiniens prochaine l'arrestation de
chacun le second c'était vraiment tendu
toits de la ville que le ministre de la
défense début du voyage de monsieur
giscard d'estaing dans le sud ouest
accueille salué m saint girons dans
l'ariège a même récemment bruyant à foix
mais de toute façon est en campagne
déjà avec deux des aspects de son voyage
les économies régionales en difficulté
et les remèdes à y apporter et l'autre
par le dialogue avec l'opposition
ses vertus kozak ces obstacles fillon
l'ins nos envoyés spéciaux que la 18 e
mails et patrick de carolis vertus et
difficultés du dialogue à six en
quelques mots pourrait se résumer sa
première journée présidentielle de la
région midi d'hier à un taux l'assagir
on est à fois au coeur de ce département
de l'ariège qui est traditionnellement
une terre d'opposition et de
contestation et où le chef de l'état
1914 son moins bon résultat c'est en
effet le souci de concertation qui a
dominé une concertation réussie avec les
élus les parlementaires socialistes
ayant réservé un bon accueil au
président apprend qu elle seule doit
perdre la face il sacrifier son droit à
la différence et ses préférences
personnelles dit monsieur giscard
d'estaing mais il faut se mettre
d'accord sur des solutions concrètes
pour faire face aux problèmes actuels et
à venir
une concertation plus difficile à la
base comme en témoignent les
manifestations organisées à foix dans la
cgt la cfdt et certains agriculteurs un
dialogue en tout cas qui se poursuivra
demain avec notamment la rencontre de
villefranche de rouergue avec robert
fabre un dialogue dont le chef de l'état
parce que quelques phrases les contours
et les perspectives du groupe
vous avez rappelé que danse un état
démocratique
la conviction qu'ils ne sont pas
inconciliables un trône pour pouvoir se
comprendre sinon pour toujours son
créateur
il faut d'abord rendre la force de la
démocratie ne réside pas dans le
monologue du vin qu elle réside dans le
dialogue 40 ce qui est important
lorsqu'on conduit par levante
démocratique
la politique de la france
dans les sondages et s'il est même temps
elle est favorable
ce qui est important c'est ce qui se lit
dans le regard de nos enfants c'est en
effet le jugement que nous on a peur
lorsqu'ils seront alors que monte à la
tête des affaires de la france porteront
sur notre action publique et je ne
voudrais pas qu'il puisse dire un solo
que nous avons sacrifié la préparation
de leur avenir à je ne sais pas faire de
préséance secondes
saint girons au coeur de l'ariège
première étape de ce voyage officiel
l'exode rural et pourtant c'est ici que
le président de la république en face à
la jeunesse de tout le midi pyrénées une
jeunesse que nous devons aider a précisé
le chef de l'état
pour cela trois directives soutenir
l'activité des villes et animer les rues
développer les riches sera durablement
seconde étape fois ruemasson socialiste
et contestée vous allez le voir bain de
foule suivi de manifestations aux
premiers rangs de la contestation les
syndicats le parti communiste et la
fnsea à l'hôtel de ville le président
l'a épaulé par didot les priorités à
l'école d'une union plan national d'une
priorité à l'hydraulique à l'action
foncière au développement de l'élevage
l'article 40 de la constitution permet
de l'auvergne où l'on donnait réseau
responsabilité sur le vote d'un texte et
c'est ce qui pourrait se passer à propos
du budget si le gouvernement de moyens
avec le rp l'article 49 mais moi je ne
veux pas qu'on joue la république au 49
comme au cap 21
le rpr olivier qui faisait partie de la
délégation de partir aux suspects
pendant une heure par le premier
ministre pour l'instant il n'est rien
sorti de cette rencontre mais il est
possible que d'ici samedi
une autre entrevue de conciliation et
lieu à l'hôtel matignon si le
gouvernement aura les gueux le salon
commence aux députés il est alors
certains péquistes et les socialistes
ont déposé séparément deux motions de
censure que le rpr ne votera pas et
c'est alors que le budget sera voté le
procureur de la république du tribunal
de paris vient de rendre public les
résultats de l'enquêté en données
sauvegardées des sceaux alain peyrefitte
sur une possible violation du secret de
l'instruction dans la sphère de
ramatuelle un placement dans la sphère
moule
la lettre écrite par l'ancien ministre
du travail avant son suicide avait
affirmé qu'il y avait eu violation de
glace que des documents avaient été
fournis à la grèce qui on a vécu le plus
directement connaissance
le promoteur immobilier tournai est un
jeune juge d'instruction comme résultat
de niang au coeur de la ville vient
trois résultats très importants
premièrement aucun journaliste dit le
procureur de la république
aucun journaliste n'a déclaré avoir
recueilli d'informations milieux
judiciaires comme le disait roberval
deuxièmement le juge de quinze juges van
ruymbeke affirmé n'avoir jamais eu
d'entretien avec un journaliste c'est
d'être aussi écrit dans la lettre de
robert bull enfin troisièmement aucune
personne tenue au secret de
l'instruction n'a violé ce secret en vue
ce que bauer henry tournée qui lui
n'était plus tenu au secret a
effectivement divulgué oralement ou par
écrit mes informations certains journal
et henri qu'on aimerait d'ailleurs
précisé au juge que le premier article
publié dans un hebdomadaire sur cette
affaire de ramatuelle avait été inspiré
par robert boulin lui même
en tout lanta 6 faire tomber par avance
les cas l'accusation dirigée contre le
mans on notera que le directeur de cet
hebdomadaire auquel les dire non et tous
nous en conclusion avant tout les
résultats de cette enquête menée c'est
exceptionnel très rapidement et c'est ça
a été fait la demande du président de la
république dans ses conclusions
remettent profondément en cause un
certain nombre d'accusations de robert
boulin porter dans sa lettre au
département belfort presque mort leur
solidarité avec les grévistes d'alstom
atlantique belfort ville fermée les
syndicats ont fait barré toutes les
routes puis les voies de chemin de fer
il fait froid à belfort mais c'est dans
le cadre de la deuxième jour de grève
qui est arrivé ce matin plus changer de
travail venus rencontrer
l'intersyndicale d'alstom les
discussions ont porté sur le treizième
mois les salaires et les relations
sociales dans l'entreprise
j'ai dit que la journée avait commencé
dans le canadel formé en fin d'après
midi plusieurs centaines de manifestants
se sont quelque peu opposés aux forces
de l'ordre et whistler
il ya eu un attentat contre le train à
grande vitesse opérationnel dans
l'enceinte de l'usiné alstom selon la
direction qui a porté plainte
l'explosion a fortement endommagé le tgv
selon les syndicats les dégâts sont peu
importants et ses provocations
d'éléments extérieurs à l'entreprise sur
place à belfort bruno masure le
mystérieuse attend pas contre le tgv
nord gaye 2
faure démontre qu'à la direction de lens
est cité dans camera régiment de mal au
cul passion illégal et dangereux et
s'installent à temps complet une
provocation et répète volontiers il
s'agit du quatrième siège de belfort et
nous le gagnerons car nous avons l'appui
de la population et c'est sans doute
pour montrer que leur composition
je me serais 52 conflit les grévistes
ont bloqué une bonne partie de la
journée
tous les axes routiers et ferroviaires
menant à belfort avant 2009 dans le
centre de l'allemagne dans les temps
mise à part quelques-uns contre belfort
ville encerclée un symbole pour les 5-6
allemand en ligue 2 pendant plusieurs
heures
défendre leur dossier avant de
rencontrer demain la direction locale
des sans voix de mon petit mentale
efficace au kiosque qui leur apparaît
sous être une diversion destinée à faire
courir la grève les cadres eux semblent
beaucoup plus tenté de faire confiance
aux médias afin de trouver les portes à
17 ans lara
tel est bien le problème le sortie après
sept semaines de grève
pratiquement ici tout le monde garde
encore son calme mais personne ne peut
se permettre de perdre la face et chacun
entend bien en finir rapidement avec ce
qui domine le gardien gelés aux produits
dlp qu'une émeute est l'une de plus en
pus bras sur la durée et l'aménagement
du temps de travail la négociation
repris cet après midi entre le patronat
et les syndicats est elle a été beaucoup
plus difficile beaucoup plus difficile
que prévu pendant cinq heures les
dirigeants des caisses de toutes les
centrales syndicales plus rentrer
nouveaux angles les points de vue des
uns et des autres ne se sont pas
rapprochés
il n'y a ni rupture ni accord
ainsi d'autres devraient suivre quatre
autres d'ailleurs de 8 janvier 1980
quand l'avion du président de la
république en route pour le midi
pyrénées a été pris en charge par les
contrôleurs de l'espace aérien de
l'ouest qui scinde en cas de ces
contrôleurs ont envoyé le message
suivant devant le sympathique de la
situation contrôleurs aériens vous
adressent leurs voeux les plus pressants
pour ouverture des négociations et vous
assurent de leur volonté de sauvegarder
le service public haute considération
ce n'est pas la première fois et ce
n'est sans doute pas la dernière que les
airs mais aussi elle s'oppose à leur
autorité de tutelle le ministère des
transports je confie ne porte pas le nom
de grève
les aiguilleurs du ciel ont perdu le
droit tout faire à lui seul 15 ans c'est
d'ailleurs une de leurs revendications
mais grève ou pas grève
les conséquences pour les passagers sous
les maps pas de vol c'est une usine à nu
la suivante en s'opposant en journée
entre 8h et 19h en tout cas samedi et
dimanche de 14h à 17h30
et conséquence également panis est aussi
frappant quand 40 et 50 millions
certaines compagnies régionales comme
tout renner transports ont mis leur
personnel au chômage technique est
suspendu leurs activités
quelques-unes même serait au bord ou les
méritants et ralp sera le traitement le
point sur l'origine de ce conflit
4 heures en fait le problème qui n'a
jamais été résolu et celui de la
réorganisation de cette profession une
nouvelle organisation passant par un
remaniement des effectifs
il n'accepte pas que technique et
contrôleur en effet contrairement à ce
que l'on croit il ya deux catégories
d'aiguilleurs du ciel tout d'abord les
couleurs
des populations de 2500 ce sont eux qui
ont les yeux fixés sur le radar afin
d'éviter toute collision que les 1000
techniciens de la défense autre
catégorie de contrôleurs mais affecté
primitivement à des tâches plus
administrative mais tout ce que le
technicien se retrouvent ni pour
dénoncer la pollution de travail
conditions telles qu'elles posent le
problème de la sécurité des passagers
maintenant la sécurité très gravement
mise en cause dans tous les rôles rond
pour plusieurs raisons comme d'effectifs
importants dès lors le fait du lac leman
monsieur machenaud envisage maintenant
de supprimer le contrôle à certaines
heures sur mon coude aérodrome profit
leurs arguments les contrôleurs affirme
qu en période de pointe
ils ont à traiter deux fois plus
d'avions qui ne doivent le faire
réglementer europe qui ferment des
transports sur ne conteste pas leurrer
on appris que la sécurité n'est pas mise
en cause
la sécurité n'a jamais été nos
équipements sanglots nos valeurs
indiscuté la france est un des trois
pays principaux exportateurs de matériel
du contrôle de la circulation aérienne
et de radars et les échos font que nous
avons sont les mêmes que ceux qui se
trouvent dans les pays les plus évolués
le compte actuellement les contrôles
l'autorité de tutelle semble tourner au
dialogue de sourds
chacun restant sur ses positions non on
parle pour but de gêner les usagers ou
les compagnies font tout simplement y
aurait il simplement
et nous disons que s'il n'y a pas des
deux soeurs et bien même si le mouvement
s'arrête la question se reposera d'ici
quelques mois
le durcissement conduit à des
affrontements dans lesquels l'autorité
de l'état et mhi encore black et par
conséquent qu'ils ne peuvent trouver de
solution dans un abandon des
prérogatives de l'administration dans
ces conditions on peut se demander si le
mans n'est plus rama militaire à
précédent c'est également l'occasion de
poser à nouveau le problème du droit de
grève dans le service public et du
commerce extérieur en france ne sont pas
fameux pour le mois d'octobre déficit 2
milliards 798 de près d'un milliard de
plus près c'est nous deux est nettement
des chiffres publiés par le ministère du
commerce extérieur
d'une part le déficit énergétique s'est
accru en faveur en valeur
et de façon importante et puis les prix
à l'importation autour des bassins en
quatre pour cent depuis le début de
l'année un élément est favorable le
secteur agroalimentaire qui accuse un
excédent de 373 millions un chiffre qui
vient à point alors que se déroule à
paris les premières assises
agroalimentaire dont le nouveau
secrétariat de mairie
l'ancien leader du syndicalisme agricole
estime qu'il pourra parvenir à
l'objectif du président 20 milliards
d'excédents dans sept grandes marques
dans ce à condition de rendre les
industrie plus compétitive et les
rapports meilleur entre la production et
la transformation pour l'instant
l'agriculture est loin d'être étrangère
de la france parce que nos produits
alimentaires sont en retard sur leurs
concurrents européens que représente
notre père jean-claude cette entreprise
est née en 1864
c'est l'une des affiches type sur
lesquelles repose notre industrie
alimentaire
elle est à l'image de l'élu le
traditionnel en évolution avec des
freins liés aux structures et soro à la
crainte
monia une aide investissent le moyen
c'est généralement la fusion avec une
autre affaire ici en 1965 puis
l'intégration avec un groupe qui se
diversifie
jacquin que l'allemand été racheté et
les 100 chevaux d'âge millions de francs
progresse grâce à des produits nouveaux
et à l'exportation bonbons chocolats et
dragées en europe en amérique latine et
dans les pays à un autre type d'affaires
familiales
beulin les biscuits fondée en 1902 par
gustave irak depuis la sphère après ses
meilleurs fils est pas étrangère
agressive elle s'est associée en 63 au
1er bis pitié mondiales nationales là
aujourd'hui avec trois unités à
l'angleterre le pays brillent veulent un
cube 1200 personnes
les exemples de ce genre sont nombreux
dans l'industrie agroalimentaire mais on
constate bien souvent que les
entreprises vont se sauver les ennemis
par développer grâce à des qualités
froment malheureusement la balance et
cohabitent ici de près de 2 milliards de
francs à moins de tenir compte des vins
et spiritueux
le résultat est alors favorable 2,4
milliards et demi de francs par
l'agroalimentaire en tout cas nous
jouons heureux que 18% de
l'agroalimentaire est constitué pour les
exportations en vin & sprit
ça représente quelques chiffres sans
présenter des vidéos le marché commun
dans son ensemble et le client numéro un
mais en dehors du marché
dans ce qu'ils font et même maintenant
journaux qui n'est pas mauvais du tout
cook est un excellent remise en forme
c'est une concurrence à laquelle il faut
porter attention qui viennent
évalue-t-il et hier extrêmement
dynamique et celle de la viande
et là il ya un problème le premier pays
d'europe pour l'élevage est déficiente
ou en viande de naufrages de bateaux ni
fait dire aux responsables de la guanine
en irak retard de notre âge est devenu
le pen l'expansion les industries de
transformation
pour michel de baptiste est une question
d'état d'esprit avant tout il faut
parvenir à faire travailler ensemble
tous ceux qui se considèrent comme les
accusés alors virtuellement les mêmes
objectif conquérir des débouchés nous
vous en étant compétitifs sur le marché
mondial des os du prix des pneus de 5%
en moyenne d'ici à la fin novembre chez
michelin c'est décidé les autres
fabricants devraient relever
prochainement leur talent heures ce
matin le mod la rue pour le 3e tour en
raison d'un conflit portant sur le
contrôle informatique de la production
que le personnel refuse lui à marseille
leur établissement et il faut les
supprimer et monsieur gaston defferre le
maire de la ville estime que la régie du
métro marseillais n'a pas les moyens de
verser 7 le casino de trouville est
occupée levé ce matin par son personnel
les 47 salariés entendent avoir l'amour
à dire sur le choix du prochain
acquéreur de l'établissement est fermé
depuis plusieurs jours en raison d'une
brusque chute de ses recettes
le sénateur dominique pablo a été élu
président de la délégation parlementaire
pour la radio et la télévision a disparu
justement les trois blessés c'est encore
ce soir le bilan provisoire de la
collision entre un pétrolier roumain et
un cargo grec dans le bosphore convoqué
le 3 viron amusions évidente et 70 la
fumée envahit du ciel la navigation a
été suspendue jusqu'à nouvel ordre entre
la mer noire et la mer de marmara où une
foule vers le marais de kaw 15 mille
tonnes
et puis nous venons de recevoir les
premières images du tremblement de terre
d'hier ans le nombre des victimes du
séisme ses premières varie entre 250 et
500 ne vont pas ce soir l'information
plus précise selon la radio iranienne et
bien les hôpitaux de la région touchée
c'est à dire près de la ville de meched
ne peut faire face à la situation car
les wc sont au quotidien attentat contre
l'ambassadeur d'israël le ch a trouvé la
mort dans un attentat il a été tué par
balle et puis encore un attentat au pays
basque espagnol un lieutenant colonel a
été grièvement blessé par trois jeunes
gens qui ont ouvert le feu alors que le
militaire sortait de son domicile
l'auteur jean pierre berthet une famille
l'oncle vernon à l'honneur aujourd'hui
en effet c'est hier soir en espagne la
mairie de barcelone que le chroniqueur
judiciaire de tf1 rose hill plywood à 70
mais a obtenu cette action reportage sur
un procès à téhéran diffusé en juin
dernier dans notre magazine l'événement
sur cette antenne 15 télévision
l'édition concept d'une audace en
désignant le jury de barcelone a voulu
récompenser le site le caractère
exceptionnel du document et sa parfaite
réalisation
décidément tes
aujourd'hui le prix cammas à maurice
fall vic et ronny coutteure pour le
téléfilm mésaventure d'yves on dit bus
qui sera diffusé ultérieurement
cette rencontre de mer du kansas city et
les valentinois club banal s'il vient
déjà de philadelphie en voulant marquer
un point n'avait pas fait exploser le
panneaux de plexiglas regard des biens
qui supporte le panier il n'y a pas eu
de blessé mais il a fallu plus d'une
heure pour ramasser lumière avant enfin
si vous avez joué le tiercé pour le
14ème 16h11 vous voyez sur votre ipad
rentrer dans l'ordre pour 5 francs 2332
francs 50 et dans un ordre différent
toujours pour 5 francs 480 baisser
sensiblement notamment dans le sud ouest
la région centre est l'alsace la
lorraine et limo et variable les nuages
seront nombreux près des côtes de la
manche et de l'atlantique le matin
accompagné d'averses de pluie de neige
grésil
on observera des gelées faible du verbe
ainsi que le brouillard il uniquement
des averses se développeront dans
l'après-midi habitations plus rhin que
même les averses dans la vallée du rhône
et sur le pourtour méditerranéen où le
mistral et la tramontane soufflant la
réputation des estampes japonaises
d'osaka
même si elle doit souffler aujourd'hui
comme moyen de séduction
et on ne dit plus venez chez moi voir
mais estampes japonaises ont dit viens
chez moi il ya du feu ces estampes
consacré illustrer un plaisir de la vie
ou jama 17e au 19e siècle constitue
parfois des trésors pour les
collectionneurs la preuve aujourd'hui la
collection réunie au début de siècle en
berne est devant claudine est de
récupérer a été dispersée dans une vente
aux enchères à l'hôtel drouot et ce fut
une vente record 4 400 milles
parmi les acheteurs s'énerver il y avait
57 japonais christiane de la croix
ce rare critique de la fin du xviiie
faire signer aux tamaru le boss à temps
c'est l'une des cinq sens au parc est
constitué reliques obernai de level
group en primitif classique et paysages
une collection édifié avant 1935 par un
occidental japonisant qui sut découvrir
les richesses de l'image d'une cure de
l'existence humaine
pour la première mais aujourd'hui un
double auprès des images symboliques du
japon ce traditionnel le japon moderne
avec sa technique de pointe orchestre
elle ne voit qu'un me croire cher en
monnaies étrangères
la terre est grandissant des japonais
pour ses estampes et aujourd'hui de
nature un public tout le marche donc
forcément le marché car les japonaises
recherchent maintenant leur art
traditionnel et sont à la recherche de
racines qu'ils ont laissé partir en
occident au début de ce siècle et la
puissance d' ordonner l que forcément la
prison sans les enjeux là même en
discuter entre japonais américains et
allemands des français ont fait
singulièrement monter les coûts ce
recueil dockside dessiner vers 1829
pièce maîtresse de cette simple mise à
prix j'ai le niveau
quatre cent mille francs emporté par un
groupe anglo américains les japonais ont
acheté de très belles planches elle vous
retourner à leurs sous le soleil levant
voilà bonne soirée à toutes et à tous au
nom de toute l'équipe de tf1 avec le dit
et le dernier journal avec nos impôts
matin 12h10